اثار مسلسل بنك كريدي سويس العريق الذي
انتهت ازمته بعمليه ادماجه مع البنك
المنافس
اثار رده فعل عالميا لم يحدث منذ جائحه
كورونا في ذروتها اذا اعلن مجلس الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي انضمامه الى البنوك المركزيه في
كندا وانجلترا واليابان والاتحاد الاوروبي
وسويسرا في اجراء منسق لتعزيز السيوله في
السوق وتعهد البنك المركزي الاوروبي
بتقديم قروض لدعم بنوك منطقه اليورو اذا
لزم الامر قائلا ان انقاذ كريد سويس ضروري
لاستعاده الهدوء في السوق المصرفي وكريدي
سويس هو اكبر البنوك تاثرا باضطرابات
الاسواق العالميه التي نجمت عن النياري
بنكاي سيليكون فالي وسجنتشر في الولايات
المتحده ولا يزال القطاع المصرفي
والامريكي يعاني مشكلات وقد استمرت الضغوط
على اسهم البنوك بالرغم من تحرك عده بنوك
كبرى
لايداع 30 مليار دولار في بنك فيرست الذي
تاثر جراء انهيار بنكي السيليكون فالي
وسجنتشر
وكانت السلطات السويسريه قد اعلنت تخصيص
نحو
260 مليار فرانك سويسري اي مئتين مليار
دولار لانقاذ بنك
بعد موافقه
على شراء منافسه
[موسيقى]
السويسريه ضمن حزنه توفير السيوله في
حالات الطوارئ وكان كريدي سويس ويو بي اس
ضمن مجموعه مكونه من 30 بنكا عالميا مهما
تراقبها الجهات التنظيميه عنك
تنضم الينا من لندن في كيبرايز كبيره
المستشارين الاقتصاديين في مركز ابحاث
الاقتصاد والاعمال
البريطانيه سيده فيكي مرحبا بك
يعني عمليات الاستحواذ هذه على البنوك
التي تواجه مصاعب كريد سويس
حتى الان لم تؤثر ايجابا على
الاسهم والاسواق العالميه وحتى يعني بدل
ان تطمان تزيد المخاوف على بنوك اخرى
لماذا
من
المفاجاه بمكان ان
مصرفا كبيرا مثل هذا تاريخه عريق ان يوقع
ان يواجه مشاكل مثل هذه وان يستحوذ عليه
من قبل
طبعا هذا الصفقه كانت كبيره لضمان ان
البنوك المركزيه موجوده وهي تحاول توفير
تطمينات للاسواق وان التكشف الاحداث كما
كان حتى الان قد طمنت الاسواق حتى اللحظه
طمنتنا على البنوك الكبيره على الاقل بان
الامور ستكون على ما يرام لكن ما تزال
هناك مخاوف حول ما يحدث في الوقت المتحده
الصوت يتقطع من عند المصدر
حيث كانت حاجه للمزيد من الدعم
للبنوك والناس ما زالوا يسحبون ودائعهم
اذا هناك
الصوت تتقطع من المصدر
حيث اجزاء من القطاع المالي
انا
صعوبه وكذلك
عملائهم هناك مشكله اكبر يجب ان ينتبه
اليها ليس فقط ما يحصل للبنوك الكبرى ولكن
هل نحن حقيقه اضعفنا النظام المالي برمته
في العامين الماضيين بسبب الاداره الماليه
ساكون اكثر شفافيه ووضوحا هل نحن امام
ازمه
مصرفيه عالميه
وبالتالي امام ازمه ماليه عالميه نتيجه
احجار الدومينو المتمثله بالبنوك
التي تواجه مصاعد
انما سنراه
شبه مؤكد هو سيكون هناك المزيد من الحذر
فيما يتعلق
بالقراض وربما هناك توقعات
تشير الى تباطؤ في معدلات النمو في اوروبا
اذا ربما ليس ازمه ماليه كامله وشامله لكن
بالتاكيد الكثير من القلق حول التنظيمات
الماليه موجوده بشكل فعال وهل ستبقى
البنوك تقرض بعضها البعض وتثقوا ببعضها
البعض خاصه تتعلق باقراض الشركات الناشئه
وشركات التقنيات العاليه طبعا هذه
التداعيات قد لا تصل الى درجه مفعول لعبه
الدومينو تساقط احجارها لكن سيكون هناك
نظره اكثر حذرا الى الكيفيه التي ينظم بها
هذا القطاع وهل ان السياس
يتقطع من المصدر
ربما سوف نرى
المزيد من
رسمله وسيوله من جانب الحكومات
للضمان ان البنوك ستستمر في الاقراض والا
سيتراجع الاقرار في وقت الاقتصاد العالمي
بامس الحاجه الى اعاده النمو بعد جائحه
وقتنا لكن يبقى السؤال عمن يدفع هذه
الاموال والى اي مدى يعني دافع الضرائب
ومن يتحمل
المسؤوليه في نهايه المطاف فيكي برايس من
لندن كبيره المستشارين الاقتصاديين في
مركز ابحاث الاقتصاد والاعمال البريطانيه
والمستشاره الاقتصاديه السابقه لدى
الحكومه البريطانيه اشكرك جزيلا
[موسيقى]